this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms on artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week he's taking a look at new Warhammer
40 000 Boomer shooter bolt gun this is
probably a rabbit hole like an illiford
go down
make sure to subscribe and let us know
other games or guns you'd like to see
Jonathan break down in the comments
section below and make sure to check out
our other warham related video where we
have an armor expert breakdown the arms
and armor of Warhammer right let's take
a look at the grimdark weapons of bolt
gun
ready your weapon
so still just looking at the overview of
this of the classic Bolter here I'm
always going to be struck by the fact
there's no blood stuck on it the winged
skull the symbolism the gold and the red
uh it's it's a sort of you know Imperial
slash religious overtones to a weapon
that I'm hard-pressed to think of a a
real world parallel to at the moment we
have sort of gilding and even velvet on
Royal Firearms going way back to Henry
VIII so that's not so unusual I've seen
skulls on on guns there's a set of
dueling Pistols that are a former gun
maker here at the armor he's had in once
that had skulls on on the breaches that
was in Gold that was very taken with
ammunition wise we get a nice shot of
the round in the magazine as it goes in
and then we see them sitting on the
table and they are closest parallel is
the 40 millimeter grenade round that we
have today but apparently and we'll see
how much this is significant in the game
it's a rocket bullet still in a case so
there's still a case that is ejected but
then we have
um
those of you who've been following us
for a while might remember this chunk of
wood that's uh how far a gyro jet bullet
penetrated into a piece of uh Pine but
uh it's suffice to say if it can go that
far into wood at any distance it's not
going to do you any favors we've shown
I've shown the gyrojet pistol on the
series before so I thought what can I do
better than that two gyroject pistol
this is the best I can do for you we
have a mark one and we have a Mark II C
marked 12 millimeter gyro jet so this
was a design by MBA oh MB Associates
and it's essentially a sheet metal
almost like a toy gun is how it feels
with a steel Barrel Mounted within it
that is really more of a launch rail for
these miniature rockets and there is no
case they are caseless rocket
projectiles and they're little exhaust
vents in the back of them there so how
the how the bolts are rounds really work
I don't know but there is a significant
difference there in that they are still
cased for whatever reason it's not clear
to me why they would still need to be
cased except that it looks damn cool
when cases go spilling out of the big
handheld grenade launcher which to me is
still what this thing feels like
something we never would have seen in
back in the day with the original era of
shooters that this is harking back to is
the ability to fit different size
magazines
um you had what you had it's kind of
cool to see a machine gun-esque
lmg-esque or some sort of big box
magazine attached here to give you more
capacity you get 10 Rounds extra in
these big chunky magazines
probably about right actually given how
massive the rounds are it's more about
the effect that they're having so we've
got purple colored Vengeance rounds here
kind of intriguing that we've got some
aspects of modern gaming projected
backwards into this era of Graphics but
yeah
so the shotgun in bolt gun is
for the ball Hammer nerds Among Us
interesting because it's a very specific
shotgun it's the Death Watch shotgun
which is used by deathwatch Space
Marines who are focused in like going
into alien infested asteroids and space
Hulks and it's also I think the only
shotgun that's gonna really suit the
scale of a Space Marine as well in game
it's less strong Than The Balter like
you see a strength rating in the bottom
right
um but but against the unarmored enemies
and the the mobs It's very effective
right next up we've got what I think is
evident from the design language and the
ammunition and the way the same Trails
for the for the shots and everything
that this is a giant pump action shotgun
this is suitably proportioned and sized
for giant dudes in uh Power Armor
I normally at this point would complain
about a pump grip on a far future very
far future in this case
weapon I think the rule of cool is
sufficiently powerful in this context
that even I am obliged to not care about
that
and um yeah it works it does the job
fills the niche is is clearly
destructive there's clearly something
going on in terms of what I've struck by
in the the shots of Buckshot can we call
it Buckshot um going down range is there
are these trails and when they strike
something there's this sort of heat
impression of a hot impact
um just like the bolt gun routes so I
gather that these would be effectively
Bolter shot shells each each pellet
effectively presumably is some sort of
rocket propelled round so it gives it a
visual distinctiveness on firing because
it appears to do less damage to armored
enemies which you'd expect although in a
way there's no reason why that would
necessarily be the case with Far Future
technology you could create a spread
effect with rounds that are just as
penetrative as rifle rounds but of
course if you do that you are making
essentially one gun to rule them all and
you needn't have multiple weapons and
you need multiple weapons in an FPS on
the face of it it's fitting the the
shotgun Niche it's got the reduced rate
of fire but significant damage and the
power-ups are interesting in a 90s style
we are effectively powering up the
weapon for a period of time we are not
upgrading it and unlocking abilities
like a modern game right so I like that
I'm also seeing things flash up on
screen like plus two contempt so anyways
there are clearly some role-playing or
tabletop aspects coming into this that I
am probably completely unaware of and
some that I'm seeing but not really
understanding the context of and that's
that's great that's probably you know
Easter eggs for the Warhammer players
and yeah the rest of us can can look
them up and and get into the The Wider
universe or not but um yeah it's looking
really good gracious thing is is in
reference to uh to a a line in a book
somewhere but basically space brings off
and say
my armor is contempt like my armor is
hatred so you're just getting angrier
and more hateful as you go on damage
oh there you go oh so yeah not so much a
mechanic as a yeah more of an Easter egg
really
as a inveterate Doom player I can't help
but see this plasma gun and think plasma
gun off of Doom but um I'm very aware
that that's not the only place these
things exist major difference here would
seem to be well a couple of differences
I suppose one is area effect so in that
respect it's a bit more like a BFG but
but not fully so it's sort of Splash
damage which sort of intuitively makes
sense to me plasma hot splashy
um I'm sure that's not how it works in
physics terms we have the the heat rate
of fire thing that we've seen in other
games where it's getting well some not
always tied together but it's increasing
its rate of fire the more you fire it
but it's it's what usually happens is
Damages the gun or it reaches a point
and you're shown to hurt yourself but
you don't take damage necessarily and
it's a wait for it to reset this
actually does seem to damage you when it
gets too hot I'm not sure how that works
with armor clad hands if it's if it's
hot enough to damage you through the
armor then the armor would be trashed
surely but hey I'm I shouldn't be
looking for realism in this Grim dark
future that we are observing um as ever
it's a little hard to comment on
mechanics and things of energy weapons
suffice to say there's a a power pack
and lots of light and some particle
effects going down range but it's
visibly different and I suppose the the
good thing for the game at least is this
is a universe where energy weapons have
a niche but they're not sort of
predominant I think it's fair to say so
they might burn through armor or
something but they're maybe less
effective in other ways and maybe
dangerous as well I think it's quite a
nice way to treat energy weapons so that
you can still have your Blade Runner
aliens projectile slug throwers If
You're a Star Wars fan
but also your energy weapons and that's
I guess that's kind of where we've
bottomed out with um sci-fi these days
is it doesn't have to be just uh gritty
slug throwers or
Flash Gordon ray guns you can have both
depending on what you want
foreign
another bolt gun I think by my count
that's three bolt guns in this bolt gun
game that's good and it's a heavy Bolter
which I have heard of and my impression
is that this is like a belt fed lmg
equivalent of an ordinary motor it being
belt fed isn't really apparent I suppose
you can sort of you get a hint of a feed
mechanism that's more machine gun like
on the left side next to a skull because
of course there's a skull it's big it's
chunky
um we have a an overhand grip which does
sort of reference how you hold a light
machine gun where you would grasp the
butt stock and pull it into the shoulder
instead of supporting the weapon at the
front because you have a bipod this
doesn't have a bipod but nonetheless
somehow the hold of it does does imply
something heavier and chunkier and more
powerful muzzle flash is also increased
report sounds oddly muted I don't know
if there's a sort of in Universal reason
for that but um it's not so muted that
it doesn't come across as a big heavy
gun so thinking about I can't help but
think about how this would work if it
was real it's it's a it's an Affliction
what can I say is just because it has
what appears to be a primer on the
cartridge head does not mean that this
isn't electrically fired it's perfectly
possible that this is electrically
initiated there are going right back to
the 1890s there were electrically fired
primers but for example there's a
one-inch aiming rifle that is like a sub
caliber spotting or training actually
weapon for massive Coastal artillery
pieces so you're firing a one-inch
caliber out they look not unlike bolt
arounds that's electrically fine so a
very early form of electrical ignition
so just because there's a round primer
in the base doesn't mean it's designed
to be pissed which means
I don't have to nitpick the fact that
there aren't struck primers on the cases
okay pause there now I've heard of a
melter gun they're mostly used as like
anti-armor anti-tank
and okay I don't believe it I don't know
if the laws changed but from memory they
either work by shooting by shooting a
cone of like Fusion Energy or focusing
like microwaves to agitate
the the atoms basically
but in layman's big hot thing punch hot
hole through other things
I think you should use that that clip in
a video okay another very cool looking
weapon um a type I've heard of a melter
gun I don't know much about them but
I've heard of them and uh something to
do with heat is going on here this could
be a complete red herring guys but
um the if you've heard of a shaped
charge this is this is a phenomenon
whereby a high explosive charge shaped
into a into a hollow was found to be
able to punch through armor way more
effectively than just a block of
explosives it's the principle behind
among other things the RPG 7 Warhead
recoilless guns use it as well and it is
there's a lot of heat involved but it is
not using heat to punch through the
armor despite the acronym high explosive
anti-tank now this is clearly an
anti-armor weapon it's it's making short
work of these chaos Space Marines here
this weapon uses heat the high explosive
anti-tank weapon or Warhead does not it
actually converts a piece of metal into
a hyper velocity jet of particles that
punch their way through the molecules of
the steel that's my museum curator's
level understanding of it I don't know
if that's of any use at all here this is
a future science fiction technology but
we do we definitely get the feel of this
thing that it is hunching or trying to
punch through solid metal I don't know I
think I probably thought a melter gun
was some sort of flame incinerator type
fuel our explosive weapon I hadn't
appreciated that it was effectively an
anti-armor gun if I remember my codex
entries I think one of them lists it as
creates a beam of energy in the tens of
thousands of degrees Centigrade okay
with the point where people nearby
having to like squint and blink away
flashes of heat and light from it
always very intense when it appears in
books and law right well I think they
seem to have captured it pretty well
here there's a guy named Jurgen in um
the caifus Kane books which is basically
as close to Blackadder as you can get in
40K
I really recommend them and he's more
than one occasion just like blowing a
demon in half with this thing this is
probably a rabbit hole like an illaphor
to go down
oh yeah I have high hopes for Mr Cavill
and friends though
all right
um it's a rotary grenade grenade
launcher it breaks open much like the
milk or mgl
um we've shown an early version of that
from the collection before so I've
branched out slightly um this is
something I need to do some research on
one of a number of less lethal launchers
this is not actually intended to be
unlike the milk or a lethal purpose
grenade launcher but it does have the
rotary function doesn't break open it
has a loading gate not a million miles
away if anything it's longer
proportionately than the one in the game
the one in the game is again Space
Marine sized it's clearly immense I
don't think a normal human could pick
that up no butt stock this definitively
has a very big butt stock recommended
um or a right gun like this or for a
grenade launcher it's really not a good
idea The Recoil of modern grenades 40mm
type grenades is not huge by any means
but um if you want to aim if you want to
hit what you're aiming at even if it's
an area effect you do want a butt stock
so the milkor typically has a folding or
a telescoping butt stock depending on
the variant so what is this thing well I
don't quite know yet it's something from
the collection that my predecessors
would be aware of I need to go and look
it up but it's called the Excalibur so
it struck me as being vaguely Warhammer
reminiscent with such a sort of
mythological name that's my excuse
anyway so I'll be looking into this
um those of you who follow the Royal
Armory Channel please forget about it
because I'll probably feature it in the
future details wise a couple of pipes on
the side there don't know what they're
doing but this appears I don't know how
this has revolved if it was a real thing
which obviously it isn't reloading is a
gigantic revolver Speed Loader which is
quite funny and to think that our Space
Marine Hero has somewhere behind him a
great big pile or maybe an assistant
with a cart
filled with in grenade speed loaders who
cares not only is it an FPS it's a it's
a Warhammer FPS as well so not gonna
worry about that but just in case we're
concerned that there aren't enough
skulls on our weapons there is also one
on this too
going down another nerdy Rabbit Hole
this thing is called a valkai caliber
they're immensely powerful
bolt guns eventually replace them after
the Horus heresy this weapons probably
10 000 years old
in the timeline of this game yeah
caliber being a name that's sort of
associated with very old Firearms stuck
out as well so is it the idea that bolt
guns are actually a throwback compared
to this thing bolt guns were I believe
built out of necessity like all the
forge planets that could make this sort
of thing were lost or destroyed whereas
ball guns by by comparison were easier
to make and figure out than this yeah
intense Laser Technology Dark Age of
Technology they just forgot how to make
them so they're Legendary Weapons now
now this is this is something entirely
new to me
um the phrase that comes to mind is
grimdark phaser
then being something of a track fan this
is like someone's unbalted a ship-borne
phaser and is toting it around this is
the the beam size and strength and
effect and it just it feels more
industrial but it is a beam weapon um
changing up the gameplay quite as far as
you can with an FPS really
foreign
I've just realized that not only the the
power-ups are 3D but the weapon models
are also 3D until you pick them up so
this thing's called the grav Cannon it's
the last weapon you get in the game the
most powerful a weird one even in
Warhammer but broadly
it turns gravity up so if you're hit by
this beam it turns that person's gravity
up its mass against them and just
basically
okay
I kind of I saw the name and I saw the
weapon being picked up I thought perhaps
it was going to be
um like the the half-life gravity gun or
in some way manipulating gravity I think
it's supposed to be well ultimately
looks like it's creating a black hole
out of green space energy and that is
just pulping the enemy so the end result
is the same as getting destroyed by
basically any weapon in the game there's
not a specific type of damage that it's
causing I don't think say you know
people aren't being spaghettified that's
a real thing look it up
um actually if you've seen um certain
recent Marvel offerings you might have
seen a version of that
um but that's you know what happens if
you get too close to the event horizon
of the black hole that's that's a bit
sort of hand wave but
it's it's like a BFG 9000 but a beam
weapon and it's it's yeah popping you
with it with a black hole it looks it
looks pretty cool I can't say too much
about it because it's so far removed
from from what I know but um as uh what
appears to be the ultimate weapon in the
game
um probably can't do much better than
that
those were the guns of Warhammer 40K
bolt gun which I've had in my own for a
while myself and uh I'm looking forward
to giving that a go so it's nice to get
an extended preview of all the weapons
from the game
looking forward to that um if you'd like
to see a bit of what we do at the Royal
armories we have our own YouTube channel
we also have social media outlets and a
website and three actual museums that
you can visit if you're in the UK at any
point I hope you do and thank you for
watching we'll see you again next time